WE'RE GOING TO CALL THIS MEETING
TO ORDER THE TEN THEY ASSEMBLY
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE IS
CALLED THE WORD HAPPY NEW YEAR
TO EVERYBODY.
HOW WE ARE NOT WITH A QUAN YET
SO WILL STOP START?
?
THE MEETING THE HEARINGS ARE
SUBCOMMITTEE.
I DO HAVE SOME ANNOUNCEMENTS SO
ONE WELCOME TO COMMITTEE STAFF
HERE ONCE IN.
CONSULTANT CYNTHIA ALVAREZ AND
DAVID SWORE FOR.
FORZA.
WE HAVE NO MEASURES ON CONSENT.
MEASURES OFF WHILE WE A FILE
ITEM NUMBER THREE EIGHTY SEVEN
FIVE SIX.
WELL ITEM NUMBER FIVE AB ELEVEN
OVER THREE. AND FOLLOW HIM
NUMBER SIX AB TWELVE OR ONE HAS
BEEN CALLED BY THEIR AUTHORS.
ONE OF THREE IS HERE.
YEAH JUST OKAY.
SO RUN TRACK.
SO WE DO HAVE SOME HOUSEKEEPING
FILE AND NUMBER EIGHT AB NINE
SEVEN ONE IN FILE ITEM NUMBER
NINE EIGHTY NINE SEVENTY TO ARE
BEING HEARD FOR TESTIMONY ONLY
TODAY WE WILL NOT BE
ENTERTAINING EMOTION.
SO RIGHT NOW MOVES FORWARD TO
OUR FIRST.
BILL AUTHOR.
THEN THAT WILL BE.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER. PATTERSON AB
SIXTY FIVE.
LET ME THINK.
THANK YOU MR PATERSON. THANK
MISTER ALLEN PROCEED.
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT.
AB SIXTY FIVE.
AB SIXTY FIVE WILL PREVENT.
THE USE OF MONEY INTENDED TO TO
IMPROVE CALIFORNIA'S ROADWAYS.
FROM BEING DIVERTED FOR HIGH
SPEED RAIL MISTER PATTERSON I
HATE TO INTERRUPT YOU BUT I DO
HAVE A CORPSMAN LIKE IS TIMES
THAT SURE SURE. MAD SURVEY
PLEASE CALL ROLE FRAZIER.
FONG HERE
AND WE ARE CURRY.
BAKER.
BERMAN.
TO.
DALY.
FRIEDMAN.
GET SEVEN.
HARPER PRESENT MATHIS THEIR
MEDINA. NAZARIAN.
O'DONNELL.
WE HAVE A CLEARANCE.
I'VE TERRIBLY SORRY FOR THOSE
IRAQ'S PERSON PLEASE PROCEED
THANK AB SIXTY FIVE. IT WILL
PREVENT THE USE OF MONEY
INTENDED TO IMPROVE CALIFORNIA'S
ROADWAYS FROM BEING DIVERTED.
FOR HIGH SPEED RAIL SIMPLY.
PUT A RAILROAD IS NOT A HIGHWAY.
YET CURRENT LAW TAKES MONEY FROM
THE STATE HIGHWAY ACCOUNT.
SPECIFICALLY THE STATE
TRANSPORTATION IMPROVEMENT
PROGRAM.
WHICH.
HELPS TO MITIGATE THAT
CONGESTION.
LOCAL STREETS AND ROADS.
AND OF THE STATE HIGHWAY
OPERATIONS AND PROTECTION
PROGRAM.
I FIND THAT LAST ACCOUNT.
TITLE.
INTERESTING THE STATE HIGHWAY
OPERATIONS AND PROTECTION
PROGRAM.
AND YET IS NOT BEING
PARTICULARLY PROTECTED IT SEEMS
TO MAKE.
THIS IS MONEY PAID HIM BY
TAXPAYERS.
TO BE USED FOR IMPROVING LOCAL
ROADS AND STREETS.
MAINTAINING OUR EXISTING
HIGHWAYS
AND ADDING NEW HIGHWAY CAPACITY
TO EASE.
CONGESTION.
IMPROVEMENTS THAT WILL RELIEVE.
A DAY TO DAY COMMUTE.
OF LITERALLY MILLIONS OF HARD
WORKING CALIFORNIA FAMILIES.
CALIFORNIA HAS RECENTLY
INCREASED
GAS TAXES AND CAR REGISTRATION
FEES.
ON WORKING.
FAMILIES IN CALIFORNIA IT IS.
A.
TAX THAT IS
RELATIVELY.
UNPOPULAR IF THE.
.
IF THE POLLS ARE ANY INDICATORS.
THE CLAIM WAS MADE.
THERE IS NO MONEY.
FOR HIGHWAYS.
STREETS AND ROADS.
WHILE CONTINUING TO RAID THE
STATE HIGHWAY ACCOUNT.
FOR HIGH SPEED RAIL.
AB SIXTY FIVE IS SIMPLE.
IT WILL STOP TRANSFERRING MONEY
INTENDED AND COLLECTED FOR ROADS
FROM BEING DIVERT TO PAY OFF THE
HIGH SPEED RAIL BOND DEBT.
MEMBERS THIS IS AN
UNPRECEDENTED.
TO PAY A GENERAL OBLIGATION
BOND.
WITH THE PROCEEDS FROM SPECIFIC
FEES.
AND TAXES.
SO IT'S SIMPLE IT WILL STOP THIS
TRANSFER.
OF INTENDED AND COLLECTED MONEY
FOR ROADS.
BEING DIVERTED.
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
HAS ESTIMATED THAT THE PRINCIPAL
AND INTEREST PAYMENTS ON THAT
BONTA.
WILL COST TAXPAYERS OVER THE
THIRTY YEAR LIFE OF THE BOND
REPAYMENT.
NINETEEN POINT FIVE BILLION.
DOLLARS
IT'S A LOT OF HIGHWAY.
IMPROVEMENT.
AB SIXTY FIVE WILL MAKE SURE.
WE DO NOT PAY THIS MONEY BACK BY
RAIDING THESE ACCOUNTS.
PAID FOR BY FEES COLLECTED.
AND INTENDED SPECIFICALLY.
TO FIX OUR HIGHWAYS STREETS AND
ROADS.
I HAVE HERE TODAY WITH ME DAVID
WOLFF REPRESENTING THE HOWARD
JARVIS TAXPAYERS ASSOCIATION.
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL.
THANK YOU.
SEAT.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS GOOD
AFTERNOON AS THE SOMEONE IN SAID
DAVID WOLF WITH THE HOWARD
JARVIS TAXPAYERS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT OF AB SIXTY FIVE.
MEMBERS WE BEND DIVERTING TRUCK
WE FEES TO PAY OFF GENERAL FUND
BLIND AT FOR OVER TEN YEARS NOW.
WHY THAT CAN BE DEBATED WHETHER
OR NOT THERE WAS A GOOD OR A BAD
CHOICE THERE SHOULD BE NO DEBATE
REGARDING THE ABILITY TO AND?
THE USE OF TRUCK WHICH HE'S TO
BE DIVERTED INTO THE GENERAL
FUND EVERY YEAR IF THERE'S NO
TRANSPORTATION BONDS TO PAY OFF.
OVER THE LAST TEN YEARS THAT'S A
CUMULATIVE AMOUNT OF ONE POINT
FOUR BILLION DOLLARS THERE'S
BEEN DIVERTED INTO THE GENERAL
FUND EXISTING TRUCK WE FEES
DIVERTED AWAY FROM WORD OF IT
MAINTENANCE REPAIR AND
CONSTRUCTION.
MEMBERS OF BOGGLES THE MIND THAT
AFTER FORCING TAXPAYERS TO SHELL
OUT ANOTHER FOUR HUNDRED AND
FIFTY DOLLARS A YEAR AND HIGHER
GAS PRICES THROUGH RESCUE ONE.
AND THE FACT IS A SAID THE TRUCK
WEEK HE'S ALWAYS BEEN DEDICATED
TO SOME. SORT OF ROAD
INFRASTRUCTURE PROCESS THAT THEY
CAN NOW BE DROPPED INTO THE
ABYSS THAT IS THE GENERAL FUND
OR EVEN SPENT ON HIGH SPEED
RAIL.
YES MEMBERS THAT HIGH SPEED RAIL
TRAIN THAT GOES NOW FROM
CHOWCHILLA TO WASCO THAT STILL
HAS NO FEDERAL OR PRIVATE
INVESTMENT IS HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS OVER BUDGET.
AND IS NOT A LEGITIMATE HIGH
SPEED RAIL SYSTEM BECAUSE IT'S A
PLAN TO TRY CLIMB.
IF WE ARE TO USE MORE BONDING
CAPACITY WE SHOULD USE THAT ON A
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM THAT A
MAJORITY OF TAXPAYERS WILL YOU
TOSS.
WE HAVE A RECORD HUNDRED AND
TWENTY FIVE BILLION DOLLAR
GENERAL FUND BUDGET SPENDING
THAT IS INCREASED BY THIRTY SIX
BILLION DOLLARS OVER THE LAST
SIX YEARS AND NOT ONE DIME OF
NEW FUNDING HAS GONE. TO
TRANSPORTATION PROJECTS SURELY
MEMBERS WE CAN AT LEAST
PRIORITIZE.
ROAD MAINTENANCE AND REPAIR
PROJECTS AWAY FROM HIGH SPEED
RAIL IT'S WORRIED THOSE PROJECTS
USING EXISTING TRUCK WAIT FEES
THAT'S ALL THIS BILL DOES THE
BILLION DOLLARS THAT COULD BE
USED. MUCH MORE EFFECTIVELY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE.
IF ANY OTHER WITTICISMS WERE
MISSED BUT IS IT.
HE NEED MEMBERS THE PUBLIC.
WHO LIKE TO?
IT'S FINE SUPPORT THE AUTHORS
BILL.
SEEING NONE ANY OF THE PUBLIC
THAT LIKE TO TESTIFY. IN
OPPOSITION TO THE AUTHORS BILL.
PLEASE STEP UP STATUE AND WHO
YOU REPRESENT PLEASE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
MEMBERS LIKELY JEREMY SMITH YABE
HAVE WITH THE STATE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL.
CALIFORNIA WE ARE.
IN STRONG OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL.
AYE I'D LIKE TO JUST.
FOR THE RECORD POINT OUT A FEW.
PERTINENT FACTS FIRST OF ALL.
.
ACCORDING TO HIGH SPEED RAIL.
THERE'S OVER TWO HUNDRED THIRTY
MICRO AND SMALL BUSINESSES DOING
WORK ON THIS PROJECT. OVER
FIFTEEN HUNDRED CONSTRUCTION
WORKERS ALREADY TURNING DIRT IN
MAKING THE NECESSARY CHANGES.
TO ACCOMMODATE HIGH SPEED RAIL
WHEN IT.
WHEN IT COMES TO FRUITION.
OVER A BILLION DOLLARS IN
ECONOMIC ACTIVITY IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY ALONE.
THIS PROJECT IS A ALREADY SEEN
A HUNDRED NINETEEN MILES OF
CONSTRUCTION.
THIS PROJECT IS WORKING.
AND FRANKLY. I WOULD ALSO ADD
THAT
SPENDING ON HIGH SPEED RAIL. OR
LOCAL RAIL OR OTHER ALTERNATIVE
MODES OF TRANSPORTATION THEN.
AUTOMOBILE.
HELPS
THE INFRASTRUCTURE OF THE STATE
THAT TAKES CARS AND TRUCKS OFF
THE ROADS PEOPLE CAN GET ON A
TRAIN.
GET AND PUBLIC TRANSIT AND GET
TO THEIR JOB.
GET TO THEIR APPOINTMENTS
WITHOUT DRIVING AND THAT ALSO
ALLEVIATES WITHOUT SPENDING
MONEY DIRECTLY ON ROADS.
THE PRESSURE ON THE STATE
INFRASTRUCTURE.
THAT HAS BEEN MENTIONED TODAY.
SO.
WE BELIEVE THE HYPE YOU WERE
REAL PROJECT IS.
IS
BEGINNING TO SHOW FRUIT. OF MANY
MANY WORKERS ARE ALREADY EARNING
WAGES IN MIDDLE CLASS
LIVELIHOODS ON THIS PROJECT.
TO PASS THIS BILL WHICH IN
EFFECT WOULD.
CRIPPLED HIGH FEEL PROJECT.
.
THE WE THINK IS A SHORT SIGHTED
AND SHOULD NOT BE PASSED TODAY.
I JUST FINALLY OUT THAT WE HAVE
HAD FEDERAL MONEY ON THIS
PROJECT TARGETED SPENT THE MONEY
WE GOT UNDER THE PREVIOUS
ADMINISTRATION.
THE PROJECTS WORKING WE ARE YOU
KNOW ABOUT A THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE
TAKE A POSITION WHERE YOU
REPRESENTING NEW YORK PLEASE.
WHAT MICHAEL YOUNG WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION I'D
LIKE THE LIMELIGHT AYE COMMENTS
WITH THOSE OF THE BUILDING
TRADES BEATS WHO ARE? OPPOSED TO
THIS BILL THIS MEASURE.
IS JUST ANOTHER ATTEMPT TO TAKE
WAY FUNDING FROM.
HISTORIC PUBLIC WORKS PROJECT
THAT IS A GOOD FOR CALIFORNIA'S
ECONOMY IS GOOD FOR OUR
ENVIRONMENT IT'S GONNA CREATES
AND A GOOD JOB SO FOR THOSE
REASONS PROPOSED.
Q..
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE STATE YOUR
NAME WHO REPRESENT NEW POSITIONS
INTERNATIONALLY OF OPERATING
ENGINEERS IN OPPOSITION.
.
WE BELIEVE THIS CERTAINLY MEETS
CRITERIA FOR TRANSPORTATION
FUNDING WE ALL KNOW THAT
TRANSPORTATION.
SEVERAL MODES OF TRANSPORTATION
THIS IS A MODE OF TRANSPORTATION
NEEDS TO BE FUNDED THANK.
SWISS.
THE CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE SHANE GUSMAN ON BEHALF
FOR THE TEAMSTERS AND THE
CALIFORNIA COMPETENT MACHINIST
AND OPPOSITION.
MISTER CHAIRMAN KEEP DOWN HERE
FOR THE CESSATION CAL FOR HIGH
SPEED TRAINS I'LL JUST ADD TO
THE COMMENTS MY COLLEAGUES IN
JUST. REMIND REMIND WITH THE
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEMS
AS MISTER SMITH POINTED OUT.
ALLEVIATING THE ROADS BY
BUILDING THE TRAIN DOESN'T FACT
HELP THOSE THAT REMAIN ON THE
ROADS IT'S IT'S
SYSTEM DOESN'T STOP AT A COUNTY
DOESN'T STOP THE CITY LINES THIS
IS PART OF THAT. INTEGRATED
SYSTEM HIGH SPEED RAIL IS
WORKING AS YOU MENTIONED.
INTO CORRECT MISTER WOLFE WHO'S
USUALLY QUITE ON POINT THAT WE
DO HAVE THAT FEDERAL INVESTMENT
THAT'S ALREADY BEEN SPENT OVER
THREE BILLION DOLLARS SO THANK
YOU. ASKED FOR NO VOTE.
SWISS POLICE HERE NAMELY
REPRESENT THE SHARE NORMAL
THOMAS THE CALIFORNIA ONES FOR
JOBS IN OPPOSITION.
Q. ANY OTHER MEMBERS OF PUBLIC
THAT HAVE.
A POSITION ON THE BILL.
SEEING NONE.
QUESTIONS OF THE COMMITTEE OF
THE AUTHOR.
SEEING NONE.
WE GOT CLOSE WAS PATTERSON
CHECK.
HOW TO POINT OUT A COUPLE OF
THINGS?
IN NO WAY.
IN NO WAY WHAT I'M PROPOSING
HERE.
WHAT CRIPPLE?
HIGH SPEED RAIL.
WHAT I AM?
POINTING OUT HERE IS.
THE UNPRECEDENTED NATURE.
OF USING.
SPECIFIC.
FEES.
MONEY PAID HIM FOR THE PURPOSE.
OF ROAD STREET HIGHWAY REPAIR.
IN TO THE STATE'S
HIGHWAY ACCOUNT WHICH IS
SPECIFICALLY THEIR.
FOR THE PURPOSES OF HIGHWAY
STREET ROAD REPAIR.
AND IF YOU'LL NOTICE I
SPECIFICALLY PULLED OUT OF.
THOSE FUNDS.
THE STATE TRANSPORTATION
IMPROVEMENT PROGRAM WHICH IS
THERE. MITIGATION OF CONGESTION
AND.
MAKING SURE THAT THERE WERE
CAPACITY IMPROVEMENTS IN OUR
ROADS STREETS AND HIGHWAYS THE
LOCAL STREETS AND ROADS FUN.
AND THE STATE HIGHWAY
OPERATIONS.
PROTECTION PROGRAM.
IT IS THE GENERAL FUNDS PURPOSE.
TO PAY FOR GENERAL FUND BOND
OBLIGATIONS.
WE HAVE NEVER DONE ANYTHING LIKE
THIS.
BEFORE.
AND SO I WOULD SUGGEST WHETHER
YOU ARE.
IN FAVOR OF HIGH SPEED RAIL.
WHETHER YOU OPPOSE IT OR WHETHER
YOU ARE AMBIVALENT ABOUT IT.
THIS IS NOT THE AN EFFORT AND
NOT OF MY LANGUAGE IN ANY WAY.
ATTACKED THE HIGH SPEED RAIL.
IT IS POINTING OUT THE USE OF
MONEY THAT THE. TAXPAYERS OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
PAID EM TO THESE ACCOUNTS FOR
THE EXPRESS PURPOSE.
OF REPAIRING STREETS ROADS AND
HIGHWAYS.
AND.
IT WE ARE.
BEYOND.
I THINK
OF THE QUESTION.
OUT OF THE OF HIGH SPEED RAIL
ONE WAY OR THE OTHER.
THIS BILL IS CENTRALLY FOCUSED.
ON MAKING SURE THAT WE DO NOT
BAIT AND SWITCH.
THAT WE DO NOT WISH TO HAVE A
HIGH SPEED RAIL.
SO HARD AND SO MUCH
THAT WE WILL BEND AND BREAK
EVERY PRINCIPLE. OF DECENT GOOD
OPEN TRANSPARENT FINANCING TO DO
SO.
THE RAILROAD IS NOT A HIGHWAY.
AND.
A YEAH GENERAL OBLIGATION BOND.
IS JUST THAT.
THE PROSPECTS OF EIGHT REVENUE
BASE BOND FOR EXAMPLE.
REPAIRS WOULD BE EUROPE WOULD
REVENUE IT AYE WILK UP CLOSE.
WOULD NOT BE AN APPROPRIATE.
BECAUSE.
ANALYSIS DEMONSTRATED THAT THE
REVENUE STREAMS COULD NOT.
SUPPORTED.
SO I SAY TO THOSE OF YOU WHO
REALLY LIKED HIGH SPEED RAIL AND
WANT TO SEE IT MOVE FORWARD. PAY
FOR IT HONESTLY STRAIGHT FORWARD
AND OPENLY. WITH THE GENERAL
FUND FOR A GENERAL FUND
OBLIGATION.
WHICH IS A DAY OUT OF.
A GENERAL OBLIGATION BOND IT'S
WHAT WE'VE DONE FOR.
A LONG LONG TIME THERE IS NO
REASON FOR US TO CHANGE NOW.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
FAMOUS PERSON.
THIS PERSON WILL NOT BE
SUPPORTING YOUR BILL TODAY.
THE ISSUE OF HOW TRANSPORTATION
BOND DEBT SERVICES OF HOUSE PAID
WAS DEBATED OVER TWO YEARS.
AS PART OF SB ONE AND THAT ISSUE
WAS SETTLED.
FOR THE INK IS EVEN DRY AND S.
B. ONE.
WE WILL NOT BE READ VISITING
THIS ISSUE.
AND FOR THAT REASON.
AS I STATED WILL NOT BE
SUPPORTING YOUR BILL.
BUT INSECTS OR WE HAVE A MOTION
FROM MISTER MATHIS AND.
A SECOND FROM A CEMENT MAKER.
.
PLANS ARE REPLETE KALRA.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE FRAZIER NO FRAZIER NO
PHAM. FONG AYE AND WE ARE CURRY
NO AND WE ARE CURRY NOPE BAKER.
BAKER AYE BERMAN. BERMAN NOTES
YOU.
CHIU NO DAILY.
FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN NO GIPSON.
HARPER.
HARPER AYE MATHIS.
MATHIS AYE MEDINA. MEDINA AND
KNOWN AS AREA.
THIS AREA NOW O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL NO.
BILLS FORTY EIGHT WILL LEAVE THE
ROLE BEEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
TAKE HIS PERSONAL.
NEXT UP ARE ASSEMBLYMEMBER TING.
AB EIGHTY SEVEN.
MR PUTTING GOOD AFTERNOON PLEASE
PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE READY ABLE
OF GO.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS.
AB EIGHTY SEVEN REQUIRES
COMPANIES TESTING DRIVE LOS
AUTONOMOUS VEHICLES TO PROVIDE
LOCAL AUTHORITIES. WITH A
WRITTEN NOTICE AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES WITH THE
LAW ENFORCEMENT.
IN OUR ACTION PLAN THESE TO OUR
RECOMMENDATIONS ARE BASED ON A.
CURRENTLY PROPOSED DMB
REGULATIONS WHICH BEEN WORKED ON
FOR THE PAST.
TWO AND HALF YEARS
ON THESE REGULATIONS ARE ARE
WIDELY AGREED UPON WHERE WE HAVE
A SOME TENSIONS WHETHER NOT THEY
SHOULD BE CODIFIED INTO LAW.
THIS CONCERN CAME ABOUT OF OVER
A YEAR AGO BUT WE HAD.
AUTONOMOUS VEHICLES BEING
TESTED IN SAN FRANCISCO WITHOUT
THE PROPER AUTHORITIES.
WITH THOSE CARS BEING TESTED
WHAT WE REALIZED IS LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT DID NOT HAVE ANY
JURISDICTION.
UPHOLD THESE CARS OFF THE ROAD.
THEY CAN ONLY DO SO IF THERE WAS
ANY MOVING A FRACTION OR
VIOLATION.
AND WHAT WE WANT TO ENSURE IS
THAT LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
CONTINUES TO KNOW WHAT'S
HAPPENING IN OUR CITIES ON OUR
STREETS AND THE CONDUCT OF
ACCORDINGLY. AND THAT'S WHAT
THIS REGULATION DOT THAT
BASICALLY.
FORCES THE MANUFACTURERS TO LET
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT KNOW WHEN
THESE VEHICLES MAY BE TESTED
WHERE THE COULD BE TESTED WHAT
DATES AND ALSO HOW THE PLAN IN A
DIALOGUE WITH LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT WE WANT TO AVOID.
WHAT HAPPENED WITH ONE
PARTICULAR SITUATION?
FORTUNATELY WAS QUICKLY AVERTED
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY
CAN.
LAW ENFORCEMENT LOCALLY HAS
CONTROL OF OUR STREET.
WITHOUT I RESPECTFULLY AYE
SPHERE AYE.
CONSISTING OF HIM WITNESSES
SUPPORT HOW.
WHICH NAME HE REPRESENT PLEASE.
CHRIS ROSEMARY SHAKING UNDER
PRESIDENT CONSUMERS FOR AUTO
RELIABILITY AND SAFETY WE'VE
BEEN REPEATEDLY INVITED BY THE
NATIONAL HIGHWAY TRAFFIC SAFETY
ADMINISTRATION TO PROVIDE.
INPUT.
FROM THE PUBLIC PERSPECTIVE.
AND REGARDING AUTONOMOUS
VEHICLES WE'VE BEEN
PARTICIPATING IN THE.
REGULATORY PROCESS WITH THE DM
B. AND WE ARE VERY PLEASED TO
SUPPORT ASSEMBLYMEMBER TING
SPILLED WE BELIEVE THAT WILL.
HELP FACILITATE COMMUNICATIONS
WITH.
THE MANUFACTURERS OF AUTONOMOUS
VEHICLES AND LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
FIRST RESPONDERS AND WE
APPRECIATE YOUR IPHONE. THANK
YOU.
ANY OTHER MEMBERS THE PUBLIC
LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE
AUTHORS BILL THE STATE YOUR NAME
IN NEW YORK. REPRESENTING PLEASE
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
ROBINSON ON BEHALF OF THE CITY
AND COUNTY OF SAN FRANCISCO.
IT'S NICE TO BE BACK AND HAPPY
NEW YEAR GREAT TO SEE YOU AGAIN.
WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF MR TINGS
LEGISLATION WE THINK THAT AS THE
PREVIOUS WITNESS STATED THIS
WILL HELP ENSURE THAT ONGOING.
DIALOGUE BETWEEN LOCAL
GOVERNMENT AND THE MANUFACTURES
ITS ARMS VEHICLES THEY TEST
THOSE WILL ALSO MAKE THE STREETS
SAFER FOR OUR CITIZENS THANK YOU
MASTER A VOTE. THANK YOU ANY
OTHER MEMBERS THE PUBLIC FEEL
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
THE AUTHORS BILL.
SEEING NONE MANY MEMBERS THE
PUBLIC WOULD LIKE TO. TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION OF THE OTHERS BILL.
YOU MAKE YOUR WAY APPEAR PLEASE
STATE YOUR NAME IN HERE
REPRESENT PLEASE.
GOOD MORNING MEMBERS AND MISTER
CHAIR OR ABOUT IT WITH TECH NET
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR TECHNO IS A
MEMBER COMPANY LET PIRACY OWES.
AND HAS INNOVATION ECONOMY
COMPANIES INVOLVED.
OF FIRST AND FOREMOST TECHNET
SUPPORTS HOW MISTER TEAMS I A
GOAL HERE PUBLIC SAFETY LOCAL
NOTIFICATION. AND TOOK TWO
THOUSAND TWELVE THE LEGISLATURE
AUTHORIZED AND DIRECTED DMV TO
IMPLEMENT AB RULEMAKING. AND TO
SELF DRIVING VEHICLE THAT RULE
MAKING PROCESS AFTER MULTIPLE
STAKEHOLDER COMMENTS.
SHOULD CONCLUDE THIS MONTH WITH
FINAL ADOPTION THE REGULATIONS
AS NOTED THE ANALYSIS WE TOO ARE
UNCLEAR WAS BILLS NECESSARY
THOSE IT REGULATIONS INCLUDE THE
EXACT LANGUAGE HERE IN THE BILL
YOU'RE LOOKING AT TODAY.
MOST IMPORTANT PART TECHNO
MEMBERS COURTING IN OFFICE HERE
AGAIN CODIFY EXISTING
REGULATIONS AND STATUTES CAN
REDUCE THE STATE'S ABILITY TO BE
RESPONSIVE TO SOCIETAL
TECHNOLOGY CHANGES. POTENTIALLY
SLOWING INNOVATION CYCLING THE
STATE'S ECONOMY FOR THOSE
REASONS RESPECT WAS LIKELY ASPER
NO VOTE TODAY.
IN THIS PLACE TO YOUR ATTORNEY
REPRESENT PLEASE MARK LASTING ON
BEHALF OF GLOBAL OUGHT TO MAKE
HERS I CONCUR WITH THE RIVER
REMARKS OF MISS BENNET.
WE TOO ARE OPPOSED PUTTING THIS
LANGUAGE IN IN CODE.
WE FEEL THAT IF IT REGULATORY
APPROACH IS THE PROPER APPROACH
WE CERTAINLY HAVE NO OBJECTIONS
TO OPERATING A SAFE MANNER
WORKING WITH MUNICIPALITIES
WHERE WE EXPAND TESTING. BUT I'M
PUTTING THIS IN STATUTE LACS
INDIAN AND DOESN'T GIVE DEIAN
MUNICIPALITIES OF FLEXIBILITY AS
WE THINK THEY NEED GOING
FORWARD.
THANK YOU. NEXT WITNESS PLEASE
SPARE NAMELY REPRESENT.
ROBERT CAL AND WITH THE INTERNET
ASSOCIATION FOR THE SAME REASONS
WE OPPOSE BILL.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
MISTER CHAIRMAN WAS CHRISTMAS
KAYLEE ON BEHALF OF THE
COMPUTING TECHNOLOGY INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION WE SHARE THOSE
CONCERNS THANK YOU.
S. WINS JOHNSON AND ON BEHALF OF
CTA ALSO IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU.
THE OTHER MEMBERS THE PUBLIC
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO THE AUTHORS BILL.
SEEING YOU NINE ANY QUESTIONS OF
THE.
COMMITTEE.
WITH.
THREATEN I JUST WANTED TO ASK
THE AUTHOR TO RESPOND TO THE
ARGUMENTS.
THEY DO.
BUT TO DOING TO CLOSE UP SHOP.
ANY OTHER MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE ELECTED MISTER BERMAN.
.
MR DENG.
AS A COMMITTEE ANNOUNCES NOTES
THE PROCESS FOR DIEM VIA THOMAS
VEHICLE REGULATIONS HAS BEEN.
VERY ARDUOUS.
AND MORE SIGNIFICANTLY IT'S NOT
YET COMPLETE AND YOUR BILL.
PROPOSES TO CODIFY ESSENTIALLY
A SNAPSHOT IN TIME THAT
TODAY.
THE REGULATIONS DEALING WITH
PUBLIC SAFETY AND WHILE I
DEFINITELY AGREE THAT THE SAFETY
OF THE PUBLIC IS PARAMOUNT
THERE'S STILL A CHANCE THAT THE
REGULATIONS MIGHT CHANGE.
BUT MOVING FORWARD AND SO.
WHAT'S YOUR LONG TERM PLAN FOR
THE BILL.
AND CODIFICATION OF THE
REGULATIONS GIVEN THAT THERE'S
STILL A POSSIBILITY THAT THAT
THINGS MUCH.
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION
MISTER BERMAN.
WE WOULD OBVIOUSLY ADAPTING
KATINA WANNA WORK WITH DMB AND
ADAPT THE LEGISLATION TO MIRROR
OR TO HOT MATCH WHAT THEY'RE
THINKING WE DO APPRECIATE THAT
STAKEHOLDER PROCESS BUT AS I
STARTED.
THIS PROCESS BEGAN TO HAVE
YEARS AGO WE REACHED OUT TO DIEM
BE.
TODAY TO CONFIRM WHEN THE
REGULATIONS MAY ACTUALLY BE DONE
AND IT'S NOT ACTUALLY VERY
CLEAR.
WHEN THEY COULD BE DONE SO WE
GET A PROCESS THAT COULD BE DONE
TOMORROW OR COULD BE DONE IN A
COUPLE YEARS. WHAT I DO BELIEVE
IS THAT WE HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY
TO WORK WITH THE BUREAUCRACY BUT
THE SAME TIME WE ALSO HAVE
RESPONSIBILITY TO WORK FASTER
THAN THE BUREAUCRACY?
SO. CLEARLY PUBLIC CITIZEN THAT
WE HAVE TO HEAR FROM EACH OF OUR
CONSTITUENTS.
AYE IMPORTS WE HAD THE
MISFORTUNE OF HAVING THIS ISSUE
COME INTO MY DISTRICT MUCH
SOONER THAN THAT ALL OF YOU. BUT
I CAN TELL YOU IT'S IT'S NOT A
VERY POSSIBLE CONVERSATION WHEN
YOU HAVE PEOPLE WHO ARE
CONCERNED. THAT THEY CAN'T GET
VEHICLES OFF THE STREET THAT ARE
DEEMED TO BE UNSAFE. ON INTEL
THE CREATED ACCIDENT TELL
ACTUALLY RUN OVER SOMEBODY TELL
THEY ACTUALLY HAVE A MOVING
VIOLATION. SO WE DON'T REALLY
WANT TO HAVE ANY COMMUNITIES
SPECIFICALLY IN THAT.
CIRCUMSTANCE SO WE ARE WE ARE
VERY RESPECTFUL OF THE
STAKEHOLDER PROCESS WE WOULD
LIKE TO CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
THE. ATTACK COMMUNITY IN TRYING
TO IRON R. THESE ISSUES OUT BUT
AGAIN. THE ONLY ISSUE IS WHETHER
OR NOT THIS SHOULD BE CODIFIED A
LOT THERE'S NO OPPOSITION TO THE
POLICY.
SO AGAIN WE THINK THIS IS A VERY
GOOD OUR FIRST STEP.
I DO BELIEVE THAT THESE
PROVISIONS AROUND LAW
ENFORCEMENT NEED TO BE.
TO BE CODIFIED SO JUST TO ANSWER
WAS FRIEDMAN QUESTIONS IS WHAT
WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH THAT TECH COMMUNE YOU SEE
IF WE CAN FIND. I FIND A BRIDGE
BUT AGAIN WE THINK THAT PUBLIC
SAFETY SHOULD BE CUT SHOULD BE
PARAMOUNT. AND THAT IT IS THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF THE COMPANIES
THAT ARE PUTTING THIS TECHNOLOGY
ONTO OUR STREETS TO WORK WITH
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT. TO ENSURE
THAT LAW ENFORCEMENT KNOWS HOW
TO REACT KNOWS WHAT TO DO ARM
AGAIN THIS IS THIS IS AROUND
DRIVERLESS CARS SO THESE ARE
CARS WITHOUT. PEOPLE INSIDE SO
THEIR DEATH WE NEED TO BE
INTERFACE WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT
SO THEY DON'T EVEN KNOW HOW TO
SHUT
S. CARS DOWN. IF FOR SOME REASON
SOMETHING HAPPENS
SO AGAIN WE THINK IT'S HIS ARM.
A VERY MILD.
FIRST STEP.
BUT WE DO THINK IT IS AN
IMPORTANT FIRST STEP TO ENSURE
THAT WE CAN MAINTAIN SAFETY OF
OUR CITY STREETS.
AND I'LL JUST ACCEPTED AT MY
CLOSET THAT'S OKAY.
NEARLY MEMBERS WOULD COMMIT
QUESTIONS OF THE OFF.
SO YOU HAVE YOU HAD TO CLOSE.
OUR SIZE TO OPEN HER ROOM
MOTION.
OKAY MISTER TEAM HOW THIS
MORNING YOUR BILL TODAY.
AND I'M GENERALLY NOT SUPPORT OF
CODIFYING PROPOSED REGULATIONS
HOWEVER.
THE TESTING OF BABIES WITHOUT
THE PRESENCE OF A DRIVERS
CRITICAL SAFETY ISSUES YOU
MENTIONED.
AND THAT IS APPROPRIATE FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO WEIGH IN ON.
I HOPE THAT SOON THAT THE
LEGISLATURE CAN STEP BACK AND
CONSIDER THE DEPLOYMENT
AUTONOMOUS VEHICLES IN A MORE
COMPREHENSIVE MANNER.
HOW THE WE GOTTA BE MOVING
FORWARD?
I WOULD HOPE.
AND LOOK FORWARD TO YOU WORKING
WITH THE OPPOSITION.
TO COME TO A SOLUTION.
HARD TO MAKE SURE THAT THOSE BIG
WAY IN AND ALL OF THEIR CONCERNS
ARE ADAPTED.
A.
WHO HAS BLESSED THEY CAN BE?
BUT FOR NOW I'M HAPPY TO VOTE ON
AYE ON YOUR BILL TODAY AND LOOK
FORWARD TO. TRACKING SALES
PROGRESSES WHO LEGISLATURE
I DO HAVE A MOTION FROM.
HOPE SOME A MEMBER O'DONNELL IN
THEM. SECOND BY A YEAR CURRY.
THAT SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL EMISSIONS TO PASS TO THE
ASSEMBLY COMMUNICATIONS IN CAN
FINANCE COMMITTEE. FRAZIER AYE
FRAZIER AYE FONG FONG NO AND WE
ARE CURRY AYE AYE AND WE ARE
CURRY AYE BAKER.
BAKER NO BERMAN OUR BERMAN AYE
CHU. CHU AYE DALY.
DALY AYE FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN AYE GIPSON.
HARPER.
HARPER NO MATHIS.
MATHIS NO MEDINA.
MS IRION.
NAZARIAN AYE O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL AYE
YEAH LATER HE EYES FOR KNOWS WHO
BILLS OUT OF THE LOOP THE ROLE
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS THINK
MISTER THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLY BILL. TEN FORTY ONE
PLEASE PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE
READY.
GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS AB
TEN FORTY ONE IS ESSENTIALLY
CLEAN UP BILL ON AN AGREEMENT
ARE RELATED TO S. B. FIVE NINE
FIVE LAST YEAR FOR REGIONAL
MEASURE THREE. SENATOR BALL AND
I.
WORKED ON CLEANING UP SOME.
REVOLVING DOOR ISSUES ON THE
OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE AND OUT OF
BECAUSE OF THE SEVENTY TWO HOUR
AND PRINT RULE YOU ARE NOT ABLE
TO HAVE THIS BE PART OF ARM
THREE BUT THIS BILL. WILL HELP
US DO THAT.
AFTER I GO.
THE OTHER MEMBERS OF PUBLIC
HAVE.
A WISH TO.
S. FINDS WHERE THE AUTHOR'S
NOTE.
SEEING NONE ANY MEMBERS THE
PUBLIC WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO.
AUTHORS BILL.
QUESTIONS OF THE COMMITTEE.
MS BIGGER SPOT THANK YOU FOR
GRANT WRITING IT'S VERY.
NECESSARY RESTORES PUBLIC TRUST
AND.
THE MORE WE CAN ELIMINATE WHAT
EVEN IF SOMETIMES JUST THE
APPEARANCE OF CONFLICT OF
INTEREST THE MORE INTEGRITY
THERE CAN BE IN A PROCESS
ESPECIALLY WHEN WE'RE ASKING TO
TAKE.
OR IN THE LEGISLATURE'S ASK INTO
THE BAY AREA TAKE MORE MONEY OUT
OF PEOPLE'S POCKETS I THINK THAT
IS IMPORTANT DO SO THANKS TO
BRING IT FORWARD.
GRATEFUL TO BE ABLE TO SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SAW HIM EVER.
COMMITTEE THAT WOULD LIKE TO.
ASK QUESTIONS OF THE AUTHOR.
SEEING NONE WHO LIKE CLOSE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MR LEVINE OBVIOUS
WHERE YOUR BILL TODAY.
I'M CONCERNED ABOUT NEARING THE
POOL OF PEOPLE ELIGIBLE TO SERVE
TO THE POINT THAT NO ONE WITH
ANY TRANSPORTATION EXPERIENCE
CONSERVE.
YOU MAY WANT TO CONSIDER HOW TO
REMEDY THAT IS YOUR BILL MOVES
FORWARD AND IT'S JUST A
SUGGESTION.
BUT LIKE YOU I WANT TO DO WHAT
WE CAN TO ENSURE THE FUNDS
RAISED THROUGH ARM THREE OR
SPENT APPROPRIATELY AND
EFFECTIVELY NOT BUY ANYMORE
BUILDINGS.
THEREFORE I WILL BE AN AYE VOTE
TODAY.
MADAM SECRETARY ONLY HAVE A
FIRST PLAY ON MISTER MATHIS AND
SEGMENT IS MATH A BAKER.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. THE MISSION IS TO PASS
FRAZIER.
FRAZIER AYE FONG FONG AYE AND WE
ARE CURRY.
AND WE ARE CURRY NOT VOTING
BAKER.
BAKER AYE BERMAN. BERMAN AYE
CHU.
CHU AYE DALY.
DALY AYE FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN AYE GIPSON.
HARPER.
HARPER AYE MATHIS.
MATHIS AYE MEDINA.
MS AREA.
MS ARYAN AYE O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL NOT VOTING.
STILL ZERO BILLS OUT.
WE WILL LEAD ROLE CONTRACTS AND
CONGRATULATIONS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS.
JURY READY TO.
SEE.
TO MISTER CHU WE HAVE AB
THIRTEEN NINETY FIVE.
PLEASE
THE SEED WHEN YOUR. BREAK.
CHECK YOUR RESEARCHERS ARE
MEMBERS OF FIRST OF ALL LIKE TO
ACCEPT YOU ECONOMY HE'S A
AMENDMENT AND THANK THE CHAIR
AND. AND YOU'RE A STAFF TO HELP
ME WORK WAS A CALTRANS. ON THIS
A V. S. CERTAIN NINETY FIVE
DIRECTED DEPARTMENT OF
TRANSPORTATION TO DEVELOP. A
STATEWIDE PLAN TO ADDRESS TO
BUILD UP BLIGHT ON THE STATE
HIGHWAY AND FREEWAY. AND
EXISTING DELAY BEFORE CLEANING
UP.
THIS BILL ALSO DIRECTED CALTRAIN
TO CONSULT WAS ALL INTERESTED
STAKEHOLDERS IN THIS PROCESS.
WE KNOW THE LIVE THROUGH THEIR
LEAD LETTERS FIFTY BREEZE AND
THE GRAFFITI SPILLED UP ALONG
OUR STATE HIGHWAY IS AN
OUTSTANDING ISSUE FOR
COMMUNITIES ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
FROM SAN DIEGO TO SAN JOSE AND
OFFERED A NORSE.
NOT ONLY IS THIS AND I SWORE
BUT ALSO COULD BE A POTENTIAL
DISTRACTION FOR DRIVERS. A
SAFETY HAZARD AND THE SICK
SIGNIFICANT POLLUTANT TO TO
CALIFORNIA WITH A WATER WASTE
AND MARINE HABITATS.
.
IN TWENTY SIXTEEN CALLED
TRANSPLANT SIXTY SEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS ON LITTER REMOVAL.
HOWEVER TO CALTRAIN PLAN DID
CALTRANS IS UNABLE TO ADDRESS TO
CLEAN UP.
AND TO OF A ON THE TIMELY
MATTERS
OFTEN CITIES AND COUNTIES ALL
LEFT TO FOR.
FUND AND CARRY EL DUCE CLEAN UP
EFFORT.
AND THE TWENTY SIXTEEN STATE ALL
THAT.
OF CALTRANS SYMINGTON THIS
ALLOCATION AND FUNDING
EFFECTIVENESS.
REVEALED THAT IN COLORFUL IN LOS
ANGELES EIGHTY SIX PERCENT OF
THE SERVICE REQUESTED ROOMING
HOUSE STANDING FOR MORE THAN
NINETY DAYS.
EL CURSO SITUATIONS NOT ANY
BETTER IN SAN JOSE AND I KNOW ON
OAKLAND A'S IS CLOSE TO DEATH.
EIGHTY PERCENTILE ALL VOTER.
RICK.
REQUEST REMAINING OUTSTANDING
FOR MORNING NINETY DAYS SO IT IS
A LONGSTANDING ISSUE NOT JUST MY
DISTRICT BUT THROUGH ALL
CALIFORNIA.
MY OFFICE AND THE CITY OFFICIAL
FREQUENTLY HEAR FROM THE
RESIDENCE AT TOWN HALL AND IN
OUR OFFICE.
WHO ARE FRUSTRATED AND FED OF
WAS TO YOU A DAY LITTERED STATE
AND THERE? THEIR HIGHWAYS AND
WANT TO KNOW WHAT WOULD DO A
WHAT ARE WE DOING A OF ABOUT IT.
SO AB CERTAIN NINETY FIVE TAKES
AN IMPORTANT STEP TO A JUSTICE
LA DOES EACH YOU AND BRING
STAKEHOLDER TOGETHER. TO DEVELOP
A PLAN.
TO KEEP OUR STATE FREEWAY
PLAYING AND SAFE WIZARD I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR BIBLE.
CHRISTMAS SECOND.
ANY OTHER.
A WITNESSES ON YOUR BEHALF.
ROMERO IF CALIFORNIANS AGAINST
WASTE
IT'S BECOME ALL TOO COMMON TO
SEE COUCHES AND DRESSERS AND
TIRES AND APPLIANCES AND THINGS
LIKE THAT ST ON THE SIDE
FREEWAYS. AB SEARCH NINETY FIVE
IS GOING TO CREATE A PLAN A
PROCESS FOR A LITTER REDUCTION
REMEDIATION THIS IS THAT THIS
WILL BE AN IMPORTANT TOOL FOR AT
THE STATE AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
TO CLEAN UP OUR FREEWAYS AND
HIGHWAYS. WE URGE YOUR SUPPORT
OF THE BILL.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES THE PUBLIC
THAT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF THE AUTHORS BILL.
OKAY AFTER MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS ATTEND CRIMES OPERATING
JUNIORS OF AND LIMBO I GUESS UP
WE WE'VE GOT A COMMITMENT FROM
THE MEMBER STAFF TO WORK WITH US
ON THE BILL OF WE ARE THE
AFFECTED MEMBERS WHO DO WORK
BOTH. STATE AND COUNTY
GOVERNMENT AND.
WE APPRECIATE THEM WORKING WITH
US ON THE BILL BUT. A WE GET
WE'D LIKE TO BE PART OF
STAKEHOLDERS GROUP THAT'S
MENTIONED IN THE BILL AND BE
PART THE PROCESS THANK YOU.
IF YOU.
PLEASE GET YOUR NAME AND WHO YOU
REPRESENT PLEASE.
MICHAEL RATIGAN ON BEHALF OF
THE OARD OF SUPERVISORS SENATE
CLERK HOUND IN SPORT.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER MEMBERS THE
PUBLIC THAT WOULD LIKE TO.
S. FINES OR THE AUTHORS BILL.
AB MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
THE AUTHORS BILL.
SEEING NONE QUESTIONS OF THE
COMMITTEE.
MR MATHIS.
I I LIKE TO THINK THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD.
MY FIRST YEAR HERE IN
SACRAMENTO IRAN AB ONE FORTY
FOUR. WHICH WAS TO INCREASE THE
PENALTIES IN THE FINES FOR
DUMPING ON PRIVATE PROPERTY
WHICH SHOULD ALSO GO ON THE SIDE
OF THE HIGHWAYS ARE COUNTY ROADS
EXCEPT RAW.
I CAUTION YOU GOING FORWARD
BECAUSE GOVERNOR BROWN VETO THE
LEGISLATION BUT I WOULD ALSO
ENCOURAGE YOU AND WOULD LOVE TO
WORK WITH YOU ON THIS.
ON TO MAYBE LOOK AT THAT AS A
FUNDING MECHANISM TO HELP WITH
SOME OF THIS IS WHILE.
AS THE COSTS AND STUFF COME UP
WITH YOUR WORKING GROUP'S I LIKE
WHAT YOU'RE DOING HERE I
COMPLETELY SUPPORT YOUR BILL
LOOK FOR TO WORKING WITH YOU ON
IT.
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE OF QUESTIONS OF THE
AUTHOR.
SEEING NONE MISTER JURIES ARE
CLOSE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR A
BOAT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MR JULIA THE.
THE.
FIRST BY.
MISS MISTER IS THERE IS LIKE MY
MISTER MATHIS.
.
CHIU.
WITH YOUR ABSURD ACCEPTANCE OF
THE AMENDMENTS.
I'M HAPPY TO SUPPORT YOUR BILL
TODAY AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
STAFF TO.
THE BILL WORK WITH MY STAFF.
MOVING THIS FORWARD.
TO BE CLEAR YOU ARE AGREEING TO
STRIKE SUBSECTION SEEING OF YOUR
BILL DIRECTING CALTRANS TO.
A SPECIFIC RECOMMENDATION WHEN
IT'S.
WITHIN IS DEVELOPED PLAN.
I AM SURE WHY AM UNSURE THAT THE
BILL ALONE WILL SOLVE YOUR
PROBLEM.
I UNDERSTAND YOUR FRUSTRATION
WITH YOUR EFFORTS THUS FAR TO
RESOLVE THE LITTER SITUATION IN
YOUR DISTRICT.
HELP LEGISLATION CAN HELP
ENCOURAGE CALTRANS TO IDENTIFY
SECT SATISFACTORY HOW COME. WE
HAVE TO CHANGE.
THE WAY PEOPLE OPERATING.
HELP WATER FREEWAYS ALSO THINK
THAT THERE FREEWAYS A WELL
DUMPING GROUND. OR THROWING
THINGS OUT THE WINDOW.
THAT'S A CULTURE CHANGE THAT
WILL HAVE TO WORK ON ALSO.
IT'S APPALLING THAT. THAT WE
SPEND SIXTY SEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR TO PICK UP
SOMEBODY ELSE'S TRASH.
THOSE ARE THINGS THAT COULD
ACTUALLY GET DONE.
POTENTIALLY PROJECTS COULD COULD
GET DONE IN YOUR CITY.
MUSEUM MONEY INEFFECTIVE BEST
VALUE WAY.
BUT TODAY WERE AMONG YOU AND I
APPRECIATE YOUR FRUSTRATIONS WAS
WAIT AND LOOK TOWARD WORK
BILLION HOPE MISTER MATHIS CAN.
DO THIS THEREFORE I'M AND I VOTE
FOR FOR PASSAGE OF YOUR BILL
WITH THESE AMENDMENTS.
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO BOTTOM
SECRETARY.
KALRA. THE MISSION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO THE ASSEMBLY
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
FRASIER.
FRAZIER AYE FONG FONG AYE AND WE
ARE CURRY AYE AYE AND WE ARE
CURRY AYE BAKER. BAKER ONLY
BERMAN. BERMAN AYE CHU.
CHIU AYE DALY.
DALY AYE FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN AYE GIPSON.
HARPER.
HARPER AYE MATHIS.
MATHIS ONLY MEDINA.
NAZARIAN.
MS ARYAN AYE O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL AYE.
MR JURY OF TWELVE WITHOUT LEAVE
THE ROLE TRAPS A MEMBERS
CONGRATULATIONS.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER JOY.
AB NINE SEVENTY ONE AB NINE
SEVENTY TWO WILL BE HEARING
THESE IS INFORMATIONAL ONLY. AND
COMMITTEE WILL NOT BE HEARING
OF.
OUR ENTERTAINING A MOTION TO
MOVE THE BILL FORWARD.
THANK YOU LUXURY WILL. PROCEED
WHEN YOU'RE.
WHEN YOU'RE READY.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
CHAIRMAN.
FRAZIER AND THE MEMBERS.
FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY TO PRETEND
DUH.
A B..
NINE SEVEN ONE AND ON. NINE ME.
ON. SEVEN TWO.
I WANNA.
LABEL IT PASSED A NICKNAME HIT
ON THE HAWKS BILLS.
THIS A TO BO SO SICK TO DRAW
ATTENTION AND IDENTIFY A
WORKABLE SOLUTION. TO ISSUES
SAVA UNSECURED CARGO HOLD SIR
AND VIA A DEVASTATING IMPACT
WHEN. PASSED THE PRACTICES PART
NOT THE HEATED.
AS SUCH A PERSON STATED.
ORIGINALLY YA I WANTED TO.
I TAKE UP ON YOUR SUPPORT TODAY
HOWEVER.
.
I WOULD CHAIRPERSON SUGGESTED
THAT THERE SHOULD BE SOME MORE
TIME FOR US TO CONSTRUCTIVELY
WORK ON THIS TIME AND THEN.
RECEIVE OUR INDUSTRY WIDE TO
SUPPORT. NASA REASON NOT TODAY
I'M WHEN OUR PRESENT THE ISSUE
TO YOUR INFORMATION ON NEED NOT
OF FOR TO TAKE UP ITEM. OF
VOTING.
A RECENT STUDY BY THE OUT ORAL
CLUB. TRIPLE A FOUND THAT THE OR
FOR A THREE YEAR PERIOD.
RULED THAT THE BREEZE.
BECAUSE TO MORE THAN TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND CRASHES.
WITH A FIVE HUNDRED THE DEATH.
AND THE MORE THAN THIRTY NINE
FOLLOW SOON INJURIES UP ACROSS
THE USA.
BEING THAT THE CALIFORNIA HAS
THE SECOND THE MOST A FREEWAY
MILEAGE
IN THE UNITED STATES SO WITH THE
MORE THAN.
THREE HUNDRED NINETY FOUR
THOUSAND.
SIX HUNDRED EIGHT MEIOS THIS TOP
CYBER INCIDENTS CAN OCCUR.
MORE THEN NOW MORE FREQUENTLY
THAN ANY OTHER STATES.
THERE ARE RAGIC
INCIDENTS.
THROUGHOUT THE CALIFORNIA.
IN WHICH UNSECURED MATERIALS SO
I HAVE A COME FLYING OFF.
VEHICLES AND HAVE INJURED.
KILL.
AND ACOSTA INCIDENTS IN OUR
HIGHWAYS SUCH AND THE STREETS.
LITERALLY EVERYDAY WHEN I LISTEN
TO RADIO STATIONS WHEN I DRIVE.
I'M SURE YOU HAVE DONE SO.
A SUDDEN SUDDEN AYE ARE OBJECTS
REFRIGERATOR COUCH LADDER HAVE
FALLEN OFF ONE AND THE BE
CAREFUL.
WE WHAT HAPPENS THEIR FAUCETS A
LARGE ITEM DROPS OFF OF FOR
VEHICLE AHEAD OF YOU. THIS IS A
SERIOUS A MATTER.
IN ARE NOVEMBER OF THE TWO
THOUSAND SIX SIXTEEN.
ARE ONLY ONE MONTH AFTER HIS
SEVENTEEN BIRTHDAY.
ETHAN HAWKE'S.
WAS ONE SUCH A ICTIM
AND A LARGE PIECE OF METAL
DEGREES FLEW OFF.
A A COMMERCIAL VEHICLE.
SURE AND DON'T WHEN THROUGH THE
WINDSHIELD. OF THE CAR HIS
MOTHER WAS A DRIVING. IN WHICH.
IF FUND WAS A PASSENGER.
AND THE SEVERED THE IF FUNDS
ARE.
KERATIN IT.
AUDREY ULTIMATELY CAUSING HIS
SAW TRAGIC DEATH.
CATHERINE HAWKS ETHAN'S.
IF FUNDS A MOTHER.
HOURS SHORTLY R. TESTIFY
REGARDING THE IMPORTANCE SAW OF
DESPAIR.
THIS.
THIS TOOL BUILT.
CAN.
THIS TOOL BUILDERS SOUGHT CAME
TO KEEP BY A WERE.
ST A AND THE HIGHWAY SO SAY FOR.
AND I HOPE THAT THE ANY WORKING
GROUP BY.
THAT CAN DEVELOPER.
ARAFAT IS SELF PRESENTATION CAN
BEAR MUCH FORTS.
I'M SO AREN'T HAPPY THAT. A WE
LOOK AT THE YOUNG COOPERATION
OFF A CHAIRPERSON FRAZIER. OUGHT
TO GET THE. O. CONCERNED.
A INDUSTRY AND.
ANYONE WITH A STAKE SO ON THIS
A MATTER. OF WOULDN'T COME FOR.
AND THE WORK WITH US AND THEN
ALSO I WOULD LIKE TO INVITE ALL
MEMBERS OF THIS ARE. A COMMITTEE
TO MAKE A NAME PUT THE
CONSTRUCTIVELY HOW WE CAN. NOOCH
ALL EVERYONE CAN SUPPORT. AND
THAT WE CAN MAKE OUR FOR
HIGHWAYS US SAFER AND THE SAVE
OUR LIVES.
I.
WITH THE.
CHAIRPERSONS SO.
APPROVAL. OF WOULD LIKE TO.
L PERCENT.
MISSUS AT CATHERINE. HAWKS.
THE MOTHER WHO TRAVELS THE ON
THE WAY FROM ORANGE COUNTY.
TO.
.
MAKE A PRESENTATION OF HER
TRAGIC. DEATH OF.
HASSAN IT'S ON*.
THANK
PLEASE TEACHER NAME.
AND.
AGAIN.
OUR SINCERE CONDOLENCES AND IF
YOU NEED ANY HELP WE'RE HERE FOR
YOU GET.
PLEASE CALL.
MY NAME IS KATHLEEN HAWKS.
IRWIN.
WE WERE SO RELIEVED TO HEAR.
THAT ASSEMBLYMAN CHOICE WOULD BE
IN THERE TO SEE AB NINE SEVENTY
ONE. THIS LEGISLATIVE SESSION IN
AN EFFORT TO MAKE OUR ROADS
SAFER.
I THINK YOU.
AS YOU MAY KNOW OUR SON ETHAN
KNOX WAS TRAGICALLY KILLED LAST
NOVEMBER AS THE RESULT OF DEBRIS
ON THE FIFTY SEVEN FREEWAY.
HE WAS JUST ONE MONTH PASSED
SEVENTEENTH BIRTHDAY.
A SON A BROTHER GRANDSON COUSIN
TEAMMATE AND FRIEND.
HE IS MISSED.
EVERY MOMENT OF EVERY SINGLE DAY
BY ALL THOSE WHO ARE BLESSED TO
HAVE KNOWN HIM.
I HOPE THAT THIS BILL WILL PASS
AND PREVENT THIS UNSPEAKABLE
TRAGEDY.
FROM HAPPENING TO ANOTHER
FAMILY.
ON SATURDAY NOVEMBER NINETEENTH
TWO THOUSAND AND SIXTEEN.
AS I WAS DRIVING YOU THIN TO
PICK UP THE GIRL HE HAD JUST
MET.
I THINK YOU.
FOR THEIR FIRST DATE.
HE DID NOT GET OUT THE DRIVER'S
LICENSE.
A LARGE CHUNK OF METAL.
CAME THROUGH OUR WINDSHIELD AND
MY SON.
HE CAME AT SUCH A VELOCITY.
THE HIGHWAY PATROL OFFICERS
ESTIMATE HE CAME AROUND A
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILES AN HOUR.
THAT I DID NOT HAVE TIME TO
REACT OR AVOID THE OBJECT.
IT TORE A HOLE IN OUR
WINDSHIELDS.
THEN SLICED THROUGH MY EIGHT.
SEVERANCE CAROTID ARTERY.
AND REMEMBER EVEN HAVE THE RIGHT
SIDE OF SPACE.
IT THEN CONTINUED WITH SUCH
FORCE THAT IT BROKE HIS SEAT.
BECAUSE CONSUMER CONSIDERABLE
DAMAGE TO THE STEEL OF THE REAR
PASSENGER DOOR.
AND THEN FINALLY CAME TO A STOP
IN THE REAR PASSENGER.
SIDE OF THE CAR WITH IS CHP
OFFICER SPOUTED.
THIS CHART. WAITING AN ESTIMATED
FOUR TO SEVEN POUNDS.
WAS LAUNCHED AT US FROM WHERE WE
KNOW NOT.
BUT THIS CHP BELIEF THAT IT WAS
LIKELY DEBRIS WHICH IT FOLLOWED
UP WITH ANOTHER VEHICLE. IN THAT
HAVING BEEN LEFT IN THE ROAD WAS
ELEVATED BY YET ANOTHER VEHICLE
AND HURLED AT OUR VEHICLE AND MY
CHILD.
MY SON ETHAN WAS INCREDIBLY
STRONG I FULLY BELIEVE THAT ANY
OTHER INDIVIDUAL IN HIS
CONDITION.
WOULD HAVE BEEN LOST IN THE CAR
THAT DAY BUT MY TEETH AND NOT
NON.
WELL I DROVE HIM TO THE HOSPITAL
APPLYING PRESSURE TO IS WOULDN'T
THE DAMAGE TO HIS CRIER DID
ARTERY BECAUSE TO STROKE TO THE
RIGHT HEMISPHERE IS BREAKING.
HIS JAW WAS SHATTERED AND HIS
FACE WAS TORN OFF FROM THE NOSE
TO URUGUAY. ALL THE WAY DOWN TO
HIS NECK.
HE WASN'T SURGERY FOR OUR SIMPLY
TRYING TO STOP THE BLEEDING IN
REPAIRS FACE.
THE JOHN IS OTHER INJURIES WOULD
OF WAITED UNTIL MUCH FARTHER
ALONG IN ITS RECOVERY.
WITHIN TWO AND A HALF HOURS OF
THE FIRST SURGERY.
HE WAS RUSHED BACK FOR ANOTHER
THREE AND A HALF HOURS OF
SURGERY.
TO HAVE THE RIGHT SIDE OF HIS
SKULL REMOVED SO THAT THE
SWELLING IN HIS BRAIN.
COULD FIND SOME RELIEF.
HE LOST PART OF HIS RIGHT
FRONTAL LOBE AND THAT SURGERY
SINCE STEAMING TO MITCH DAMAGE
TO SAY FROM THE PRESSURE OF THE
SWELLING.
THE BEST DRAMA TEAM NEUROSURGERY
TEAM AND I SEE YOUR TEAM DID
EVERYTHING WITHIN OUR POWER TO
TRY TO SAVE MY SON.
FOR FIVE DAYS HE FOUGHT TO CLEAN
TO LIFE.
MORE PROCEDURES TO INSERT PROBES
INTO HIS BRAIN TO MONITOR THE
SWELLING ACTIVITY WHERE DEWART.
YEAH HE FINALLY SUCCUMBED TO HIS
INJURIES AT FIVE OH THREE M..
THANKSGIVING OR ANY.
NOVEMBER TWENTY FOURTH.
TWO THOUSAND SIXTY HE.
WHEN LEAVING THE HOSPITAL AFTER
LOSING MY BELOVED SON.
THE CAR EATEN SISTER AND FATHER
WERE WRITING IN ALSO HAD AN
INCIDENT ON THE SAME FIFTY SEVEN
FREEWAY.
AT APPROXIMATELY THE SAME
LOCATION GOING IN THE OPPOSITE
DIRECTION.
NORTHBOUND A PIECE OF WOOD
SIMILAR TO A PIECE OF THE TWO BY
FOUR.
FLUID THEIR VEHICLE WINDSHIELD
AND ALMOST INJURED WHAT WAS LEFT
OF MY FAMILY.
THIS HAS TO STOP.
GABY NINE SEVENTY ONCE SEEKS TO
REDUCE THE LIKELIHOOD OF ANOTHER
TRAGEDY LIKE THIS HAPPENING TO
SOMEONE ELSE.
HAVING HERSCHER PENALTIES IN
PLACE FOR IRRESPONSIBLE
TRANSPORT OF LOOSE ITEMS ON OUR
HIGHWAYS AND ROADWAYS WILL ACT
AS A DETERRENT.
REQUIRING REPORTS WHEN ITEMS ARE
DROPPED WILL PROVIDE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO PREVENT TRAGEDY
BEFORE IT HAPPENS.
ENABLING LAW ENFORCEMENT TO
EXACT PENALTIES ENACT STE WITH
SWIFTER. IN THAT EVENT DEBRIS IS
LOST INNER FOUND ON ROADWAYS.
WILL ALLOW A PROACTIVE STANCE
AND REDUCE THE LIKELIHOOD OF
DEBRIS ENDING UP KILLING ANOTHER
INNOCENT MOTORISTS FOR
PASSENGER.
HOPEFULLY OTHERS WILL THINK
TWICE BEFORE CARRYING AND
SECURED CARGO THAT MAY HAVE THE
POTENTIAL TO KILL SOMEONE.
ELSE'S CHILD GRANDCHILD.
PARENT SIBLING OR FRIEND.
MY SON ETHAN HAWKE SAYS GOD.
AND NOTHING CAN BRING IT BACK TO
ME.
AND THE OTHERS WHO LOVED SO
DEARLY.
AND I WILL NEVER GET THE EVENTS
OF NOVEMBER NINETEENTH TO THE
TWENTY FOURTH TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN OUT OF MY MIND.
THAT AB NINE SEVENTY ONE HAS THE
POTENTIAL TO SAVE SOME OTHER
FAMILY FROM EXPERIENCING THIS
EXCRUCIATING LOS.
AN UNTHINKABLE TRAGEDY.
I ASK YOU PLEASE SUPPORT THIS.
TO PROTECT YOUR OWN FAMILIES AND
EVERYONE ELSE'S PLEASE.
THANK YOU.
AND THINGS.
I COMMEND.
NO OH. YEAH.
ON.
THE MEMBERS THE PUBLIC THAT
WOULD LIKE TO ADD ADDITIONAL
TESTIMONY HOME FOR THE AUTHORS.
.
INFORMATIONAL HEARING.
ON THE BILL.
OKAY MEMBERS A PUBLIC THAT WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE ANY QUESTIONS THE
COMMITTEE.
DOCTORS I WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE.
YEAH AS I STATED R. TODAY'S SAW
ON NEED FOR INFORMATION NOW.
I WANNA MAKE SURE THAT THE
EVENTUALLY THIS TO APPEAR SO
WOULD BE TAKEN UP BY FOR YOUR
FOR THE.
BUT I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
ENTIRE INDUSTRY AND US STATE
QUARTERS SO WHERE SUPPORT.
AWARE IMPORTANCE OF DESPAIR AND
I.
I ASK YOU A COOPERATION AND COME
BACK IMPOSE SO THAT THAT THESE
TWO APPEARS EVENT CHARLIE WERE
SOME.
PASS OF THIS COMMITTEE AND I'M
BECOME ON ALL.
THANK YOU TO ACTUALLY.
.
AND I WANT TO GIVE YOU THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO.
PROVIDE THIS INFORMATION OF THE
COMMITTEE AND THE PUBLIC.
HOME BECAUSE I KNOW WHAT IT
FEELS LIKE THAT INSATIABLE
SORROW.
ON.
OVER THE LOSS OF A CHILD.
YEAH TO SEE CHANGES.
SO THAT OTHERS MAY BE SPIRIT THE
PAIN THAT MY FAMILY.
HE KNEW IN THE THIRD.
IT'S BEEN SEVENTEEN YEARS FOR
ME.
NEVER GETS BETTER.
ENJOYS YOU AND I.
CUST.
I'M DIRECT THE STAFF TO WORK
WITH YOU. AND TO WORK WITH
STAKEHOLDERS TO FIND A WORKABLE
SOLUTION FOR YOUR CONCERNS
BECAUSE.
I UNDERSTAND I'M A CONTRACTOR.
WHO WAS IN THE INDUSTRY FOR
THIRTY FIVE YEARS?
AND I THINK IF WE BRING THEIR
EFFORT.
BRING THEM INTO THE EFFORT WE
CAN HAVE SOMETHING.
THAT'S VIABLE THE EXPERTS
WEIGHED IN.
AND WE DON'T PUT SOMETHING ON
THEM THAT. COULD POSSIBLY MAKE
THEM A CRIMINAL CRIMINAL.
HOW BECAUSE THEY CAN'T COMPLY?
AND THAT'S ONE OF THE BYPRODUCTS
OF SP ONE WHEN WE WERE ABLE TO
DIRECT SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS TO
THE UC'S BECAUSE THEY'RE GOING
TO BE.
PART OF THIS PROCESS ALSO.
MY HOPE THAT. THROUGH THIS
EFFORT.
YOU CAN BRING BACK A BILL IN
APRIL.
AND I PROMISE TO WORK WITH YOU.
THAT I CAN BE SUPPORTIVE.
AND THAT YOU CAN MOVE FORWARD.
WITH THE SUPPORT OF INDUSTRY.
AND THEN WE CAN.
STOP THIS.
UNFORTUNATE.
INCIDENT.
TO CONTINUE.
SO I THANK YOU MA'AM FOR BRINGS
FOUR NINE ON HOW TOUGH IT WAS.
I WITH THAT.
NO WISH YOU MUCH LUCK PATRICK.
WILL MOVE ON TO ANOTHER. AND
THEN THANK YEARS JAM AND
OPERATIONAL AND ON THE MEMBERS.
THANK YOU MISS AND MRS HAWKS.
SO WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON.
WELL I AM TEN.
AB SIXTY SIX PATTERSON THIS IS
FOR VOTE ONLY.
SO ENTERTAINING MOTION.
SO WE HAVE SOME REMEMBER.
MATHESON ASSEMBLYMEMBER.
HARPER HOME THE MOTION FIRST AND
SECOND.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE FRAZIER NO FRAZIER NO
FONG. FONG BERMAN AYE TO.
CHIU NOTE DAILY.
FRIEDMAN.
GIPSON.
HARPER.
HARPER AYE MATHIS.
MATHIS AYE MEDINA.
NAZARIAN.
O'DONNELL.
SEARCHES WOULD YOU PLEASE CALL
OUT TO MEMBERS AND TELL THEM
THAT THEY HAVE.
TEN MINUTES.
LOCALS ROLE
VIOLATE IN TEN AB SIXTY SIX.
NAZARIAN.
NAZARIAN AYE.
CURRENT VOTE SIXTY TWO.
BUT CHANGE
VIOLATE IN TURN AB SIXTY SIX
NAZARIAN I'D TO KNOW
VIOLENT INTO A BE EIGHTY SEVEN
THE CURRENT VOTE IS EIGHT TO
FOUR. MEDINA. MEDINA AYE.
FINAL VOTE NINE TO FOUR.
FILE ITEM FOR AB TEN FORTY ONE.
CURRENT VOTE IS TEN TO ONE
MEDINA.
MEDINA AYE.
FINAL VOTE ELEVEN TO SARAH.
FILE ITEM SEVEN AB THIRTEEN
NINETY FIVE
THE CURRENT VOTERS TWELVE TO
ZERO MEDINA.
MEDINA AYE FINAL VOTE THIRTEEN
TWO ZERO.
FINAL ITEM TEN AB SIXTY SIX.
THE CURRENT VOTE IS FIVE TWO
THREE.
MEDINA.
MEDINA NO CURRENT VOTE FIVE TO
FOUR
FILED ITEM ONE AB SIXTY FIVE.
THE CURRENT VOTE IS FOUR TO
EIGHT DAILY. NO DAILY NOW FINAL
VOTE FOR DENYING.
FINAL ITEM TEN AB SIXTY SIX
THE CURRENT VOTE IS FIVE TO FOUR
DAILY.
NO DAILY NO.
CURRENT VOTE
FIVE TO FIVE
SO WE ARE GOING TO ADJOURN THIS
HEARING OF LEGISLATIVE. IN THE
LEGISLATIVE BUSINESS BEFORE THE
ASSEMBLY TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE IS NOW COMPLETE